hey Bill my name is Thomas and I'm from
Los Angeles California and I was
wondering if mathematics is truly
universal I'm not disputing it I'm just
really wondering if mathematics such as
calculus really like is the same near
the edges of the universe for all that
we know or like near black holes does
Masum do mathematical laws break down
thanks Thomas that is a great question
about mathematics as far as we know it
works everywhere now whatever if we go
to a place as you suggested near a black
hole the edge of the universe and
mathematics doesn't work we would say to
ourselves well there's just mathematics
that we don't understand and we have to
add some more more math to our to our
Canon of mathematical equations it's
very reasonable that there's math that
nobody knows how it works but just
understand that when it comes to the
motion of planets when it comes to how
Rockets work when it comes to the paths
of comets and asteroids meteors we
understand this stuff inside out however
it was only in the 1600s that these
discoveries were made and so you'll also
hear people talk all the time about the
singularity the singularity and this is
to me is when you get one over zero and
one over zero is infinite or it is
unknowable and I'll give you an example
what's what's 1,000 what's bigger one
tenth or one thousandth a tenth is
bigger than a thousandth okay then
what's bigger one thousandth or one ten
thousandth a thousandth is bigger all
right now what about one over one ten
thousandth that's 10,000 but one over
one-millionth is a million one over a
billion thisa billion so as the number
gets smaller and smaller the total the
inverse the the denominator causes the
total of the quantity to become bigger
and so if it's over zero it would become
infinity or infinite and nobody knows
what happens at infinity no one knows
what happens exactly at the singularity
oh-hoh people speculate oh but yeah as
near as we can tell math applies
everywhere that is a great question
thank you